Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Langfocus channel
and my name is Paul.
As you probably know.
(Nope, never heard of you!)
In this video I want to talk about something that people often ask me about
but then I don't usually talk about in videos...
...and that's how I study languages.
I don't usually talk about it because I don't want to portray Langfocus as a polyglot channel.
And whenever i talk about the way I learn
some people blow it out of proportion and they they think
that I must be some language learning master  or guru which I'm not.
and also 'cause I'm so busy making videos all the time these days
I don't to give the people false impression that I spend all day studying languages
and reviewing ones that I've studied in the past.
But with that said, I do study usually during my commute,
which is probably about an hour of uninterrupted time if I've calculated.
at the moment I'm  focussing on in Indonesian,
I studied it a long time ago, but this year I've decided to review it.